alors rumeur par humeur et la tension
commence avec du lourd
nabila prendrait des cours de poussettes
mais je suis content que c'est offrir
on aurait pu arrêter là bref au il est
possible mais ça sert et si tu ma mère
regarde ce soit vrai je dis ouvrait
annoncé ben regarde effectivement c'est
vrai on a un magnéto et puis derrière on
va en parler parce que ça fait ça fait
un scandale évidemment sur ce b6 sur
internet parce qu'elle allait forcément
parle d'un enfant donc et des
conséquences regard des eaux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une poussette électrique donc ça
la retient à peu perdre en donnons lui
dit si tu peux enlever le côté
électrique et si tu lâches bas avec la
vitesse elle paraît déjà bon sens les
mains et toi lâche sa poussette
évidemment les gens c'est n'importe quoi
on confie un enfant in crédit dont il
est dans son ventre le bébé à la pagode
bien qu'il ait pas dedans il y aura pas
coûté mais non mais parce que c'est vous
dire si la médisance et une fusion au
sport nations derrière l'histoire en
fait qu'on va dire la vérité mal et
libérale confirmer lui est un placement
de conduite et les gens et les gens ont
dit qu'elles en soient rendues
maintenant quasiment à monnayer son bébé
et n'a pas voilà pour pour pour vivre à
leur tour ont demandé à magali parce que
en plus pas guida que les très bien et
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment vous habiter
ensemble sécher passa alors quand tu es
chez toi oh bah comme ça c'est dit c'est
chez magali on peut retourner aventure
qui vaut 180000 euros bruts la voiture
la mercedes amg c'est à qui ça moi j'ai
une smart stacking plus grosses voitures
que les animateurs c'est à qui ça
revient dans sa note qu'il vient il faut
dire la vérité mais a gagné au moins tu
parles étudie tout sécher n magali est
réussi et tant mieux sans prophétique
pas tout c'est toi qui le dit mais comme
forcément par un des autres faut qu'on
parle de nous aussi sinon les gens
comprendraient pas qu'on balance et
voilà donc là qu'est ce qui se passe
avec cette poussette mais rien en fait
n'a bilal et la place aux produits mais
non alors arrêté un placement de produit
un placement à jouer j'ai offert un
cours un placement de produit ces
cantons je fais un crochet je suis une
prof aujourd'hui nous apprend qu on
revendique une marque ont la taille on
la nomme on lui fait une promotion au
delà elle a parlé de la marque a rien
dans sa chute une courroie quand
j'achète une poussette j'ai pas le bac
pas prendre la société qui vient chez
moi c'est ignoble
merci guillaume une éventration enfin il
raconte même temps qui a tenu et il
vient chez toi que tu vois la marque de
la ville je ne pensais pas qu'on aura
des bases qui est vrai magali le
représentant de la marque qu'ils
arrivent à trois avec la poussette pour
lui faire une démonstration vous
expliquer à la raison je vous le dis
puisque effectivement joua le salon
d'accord elles reçoivent des tonnes et
des tonnes de cadeaux
elle n'a jamais été rémunéré pour faire
une promotion de 7 pouces est elle
revenue à des cas nous on lui offre
elle fait ce qu'elle veut y a pas donc
c'est juste parce qu'on lui a offert la
boussole qu'un truc elle s'amusait en
fait elle malade
attendez moi j'ai eu trois ans de baby
lui proposait déjà pris la 3 mecs d'une
marque qui viennent serait qu'une
personne est elle la monte devant
instagram ne veut pas croire qu'elle l'a
payé parce qu'enfin la mélamine allons
là au quotidien mais c'est pas peu s'en
fait arrêter tout en voir le mal pleurs
alors ma galette magali heureusement que
le ballon pour que l'offre que ce que
dénigrer l'on sait faire la promotion
d'un défilé dernière que vous descendiez
commercial or dernières questions
réponses je joue laisser la parole
mais pourquoi la beach et où en ce
moment donc encore en france en banlieue
mais ça regarde père pour accoucher
peut-être non mais pour noël mais je
pensais qu'elle vivait à londres
bah ça intéresse les fans pardon c'est
adjani non plus écoutée est là
elle s'exprimera par vivre dans un autre
pays après dubaï dubai va livrer de même
que les ailes et en transition et elle
valide en transit on n'était pas loin
mais heureuse d'accord toujours des
endroits ce qui est toujours nous en
voulons c'est présents dont les actifs
d'impôts même si les maires de bien elle
a certainement envie que son fils ou sa
fille et un fils c'est ça ouais tu sois
français c'est très bien mais les
médecins sont mis à la sauce israël 27
des questions mathieu non moi j'ai quand
même un petit problème à ce que je viens
de dire magali fia nabila c'est un
panneau publicitaire certes un peu moins
plat mais c'est imparable à gagny où
tout ce qu'elle montre quelques fois
effectivement ça placement produit mais
quand ça ne l'est pas le public
il est trompé forcément là on a tous
compris combien offert une poussette est
plus là dessus et les gens disent tiens
c'est exister poussette et qu'une
assistance électrique met à l'honneur la
prochaine recrue des radars ça donne pas
le prix donc pas ça mais tu peux pas le
nier elle est même s'il ya pas un
contrat de placement produit dans les
faits pour le public c'est la même alors
et c'est pâques mais elle a droit de
recevoir des cadeaux quand même que l'on
n'a pas dit le contraire
on avance un peu de ce côté n'auront
plus que ce qu'ils vivent ce qui ce
qu'est un peu c'est le côté c'est drôle
quand elle joue un peu l'ingénierie la
peau les jo c'est l'idiote avec une
poussette s'habitue sa vie au quotidien
toute la journée we hate vous allez
apprendre de lui un franc poussé la
poussette elle le montre a passé 20 ans
dans la marque elle a réussi son coup on
parle là bas la marque et vaunage déjà à
kiev ou tacite est incapable mais les
gens à faire des recherches
moi perso elle a l'air trop compliqué à
gérer que vous faites mais moi ce que
j'aime bien chez naville assez calé sans
filtre et assez que moi en étant maman
je me souviens être resté deux heures
devant devant les modes d'emploi pour
savoir comment fonctionner le lit
parapluie
gros tu la voulais pas me comprenne je
pense que c'est vrai alors les amis ce
qui est sûr on a fait les sondages en
émettre des sons à n'importe quoi donc
nabila à lyncher sur les réseaux sociaux
vous comprenez ou pas assez mitigé voilà
le sort de ce qui sert à rien merci
beaucoup mais on écoute et le voilà il
n'y avait rien sur 12 est choquée pas
choquer